hello everyone and welcome to game 13 of
the 1909 match between josé raúl
capablanca and Frank James Marshall
previous game you've seen was game 11
where Marshall really attacked like a
madman capablanca defended like a madman
and the the end result was a just a
spectacular game where Marshall missed
at Bishop to d7 mover who he could have
at least drawn the game we're gonna skip
game 12 as it's a couple blanca won that
game also but i don't know i decided to
skip it but i will put a link to it in
the description below if you just want
to go through it this is game 13 and
again we have a Marshall with the white
pieces couple Lanka with the black
pieces they go they play the same line
of the Queens gambit declined but
Marshall goes for that capture in the
center that we've been discussing all
along that a couple Blanca said was most
likely better for white and I don't know
if I mentioned this in my previous
videos but at the time this match was
played capablanca didn't really have any
opening Theory knowledge I am of course
joking I know everyone knows that and
that you're probably you know telling
this to your friends and family but you
know just in case
d4 by Marshall and I do hope you are
having an excellent Friday d5 c4 e6
Knight c3 and 912 six again we have the
exact same line of the Queens gambit
declined Bishop to g5 Bishop to e7 III
and now Knight to e4 again with the
Lasker defense and by this point like I
said this is game 13 Capablanca is in
the lead five points the result is six
to one with five draws but two draws
don't count in this match and it's first
to reach eight wins
so quite a handicap for Marshall to
overcome but he does have the white
pieces so let's see what he goes for in
this game Bishop captures on e7 Queen
captures and now not Bishop d3 like in
previous games but first C captures on
d5 the move capablanca himself suggested
in every game they played this line
Knight captures on c3b captures on c3
and now ECAD force on d5 so now b6 is
not all that great for black because
after the bishop is if in cathode the
tabie
the d5 pawn stands in its way and Queen
to b3 now pressuring the d5 pawn also
not allowing a white black to develop
his light square bishop as the b7 point
would become a target
so c6 coupled munkar defends both
threats now the DFAC phone is defended
and the bishop can be developed as the
queen is also keeping an eye on the b7
pawn Bishop to d3 and now capablanca
castles we have nightwear 3 937 this
Knight cannot go either to f6 or if the
rook moves you can go night f8 to keep
an eye on the h7 pawn and perhaps to go
to g6 or e6 if needed we have a 4 by
Marshall and now rook to b8 here a
couple of wonk is ready to play Knight
f8 the rook will serve as additional
protection to the d5 pawn and as a
whiteskin is still in the center couple
monk is preparing c5 we have castles by
Marshall now comes Knight to a fate like
we said defending the h7 pawn if needed
so any Queen c2 will not come with tempo
also tonight can easily be remover - to
wherever is needed and also c5 is
prepared rook F the b1 you can see that
in this game Marshall refrains from
attacking the King but takes the take
the game to the Queen side rook to b8
and now we have a 5 if B b5 or b6 is
played then a capture some b6 and
poisson is ready Bishop to e6
we have rook to a4 Marshall wants to go
for rook to b4 and the put extreme
pressure towards the b7 pawn and now
everything is ready kappa blanka seem to
place c5 and this is already the
critical moment in the game if you play
d captures on c5 of course you don't
want to do this as your pawn structure
becomes incredibly messed up you have
this III pawn here the c3 pawn is weak
the the c5 pawn is a weak the a5 point
is a weak black and even go just d4 open
up an attack against the White Queen and
after the Queen moves you can go capture
seer characters here and now you have
four of these pawns that will be weak
for the rest of the game in Capablanca
sense that this is this will be winning
for black on the other hand after the c5
move the threat for black is of course
c4 this would win the bishop on d3 and
what you want to do here is simply move
the Queen let the Queen c2 and the game
continues but here we have Queen to a3
marshal the and he has he does love them
tactics he pins the pawn a son now you
can push c4 you cannot capture as the
Queen and e7 is hanging but
unfortunately for marshal the Queen a
three move is a terrible blunder and
Capablanca of course figures it out but
as you know you are watching this video
at home you have all the time in the
world
perhaps so feel free to pause the video
and try to find well we could say the
winning idea for kappa blanka here even
though it's only moved 17 I'll give you
a couple of seconds to figure it out for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's really an amazing
maneuver and for those of you just wanna
enjoy the show the idea is Bishop to d7
so you might think okay the rook is a
bit awkwardly placed on a4 but why it's
just gonna defend Bishop to b5 and this
was in fact played in the game you of
course protect the rook and now if black
captures you just capture back with the
rook but here's the problem
now comes Bishop back to f5 you remember
your bishop
with an attack against White's rook can
be won and now you cannot protect you
you can pushy for you can't put anything
in between you can go Bishop to d3 the
d3 square is not guarded you have to
move the rook we looked the b2 and now
comes a six you push back the bishop the
bishop has to go to e 2 or F 1 and
there's nothing for Bishop to capture so
this is the problem Bishop has to go
back Bishop to e2 what's played in the
game and now you simply attack the rook
that is so conveniently awkwardly placed
on a4 with Bishop back to d7 and now
that the point is an a6 the bishop can
no longer defend it and now you have won
a rook
well the exchange nicely 5 by Marshall
and now simply Bishop captures an a4 so
yes it is that simple Queen captures on
a4 and now c4 walking down this Bishop
so it can no longer be a very useful
piece well you will activate it via
Bishop to F 3 and E 4 at some point but
for now not so much here kappa blanka is
a clear clean exchange
the marshal doesn't really have anything
to show for it he does have a very
strong knight on e5 but it's
questionable how long will he be able to
stay there with h3 Knight to d7 now
going for this exchange in the center
there's really nothing to do you can put
the knight back but you want to play
Bishop to f3 so we have Knight captured
77 Queen capture Sun d7 offering a queen
trade and Queen back to a to Marshall
has no option but to retreat as the
endgame would of course be winning for
capablanca being of the exchange without
any compensation for marshal Queen to c7
now bringing the rook over to d6 to
prepare b5 as after white plays ache
after some b6 on pass on the rook from
d6 we'll be able to capture back
Bishop to f3 preparing efore and we have
rooked the d6 now II for D captures on
e4 Bishop captures on e4 and now b5 as
planned and now you pretty much have to
capture on pass on if you leave this the
formation intact then white is basically
without a move so a capture some b6 rook
D capture some b6 now doubling up on the
B file rook captures we have rook
captures and Bishop to d5 I would a
double attack against the c4 pawn and
now look the b3 cutting off the Queen's
attack there was the c4 pawn we have g3
and now comes g6 Queen to a6 capturing
the pawn but now the c3 pawn is
unguarded
so rook captures on c3 and now King to
g2 we have King to g7 and now comes
Queen to b5 again waiting for black to
figure out a plan we have Queen to e7
Queen to be to now and now rook to d3
putting pressure along the d4 pawn and
here we have Queen to c2 preparing to
capture here as there's a double attack
against the pawn here and here kappa
blanka simply played rook captures on d4
and it's another moment where well we
already mentioned that Kasparov mentions
this in his book my great predecessors
that Capablanca was often lazy and here
his position is winning it's winning in
a lot of ways Capablanca captures the
pawn because the endgame is winning for
him but if he decided to calculate even
for a sec
and as most of these moves were played
in undress under under a minute he would
have found a move that wins much faster
but you are comfortable in your own home
or on a smartphone or wherever again
Phil feel free to pause the video and
try to find the move that ends the game
on the spot I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual as you do so much enjoy
these nice nice puzzles for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
it's a it's a wonderful Queen move and
for the zoo just one enjoyed show the
move is Queen to e1 and now there's
really nothing for whites to do whatever
you whatever you play there's no useful
move you can capture the pawn and now we
don't look to d1 or rook to d2 we'll win
the game if you go rook to d2 then
there's no stopping Queen captures on f2
or you can go rogue d1 prepare checkmate
and then after white moves let's say you
place something you have to defend
checkmate so you have to play something
king of three
now you go Rudy to attack the Queen the
Queen has to move Queen b3 and now it's
simply rope captures King goes here f5
King has to go deeper in and now Queen a
7 will be checkmate and there's nothing
to do but like we said perhaps
Capablanca was lazy perhaps he just
thought that ok this endgame is winning
for me so I don't have to look any
further doesn't really matter but okay
Bishop captures we have Queen to b7
check King G 1 and now Queen the c6 here
kappa blanka basically forces a trade of
Queens and the endgame is winning for
him there should be three Queen captures
and c2 Queen Bishop captures and now air
five and of course this is winning but
it's
capablanca doesn't mind just showing how
it's winning and how quickly he can do
it we have King to g2 and now comes King
to f6 h 4 we have king to e5 bringing
the king into the game that's the thing
is well most of the times the most
important piece in the endgame
we have f4 check King to d5 and now King
to h3
marshal is still hoping to create some
sort of a some sort of a fortress
so Capablanca will not be able to
penetrate but rook the d2 Bishop to b3
checked in 3/4 we have H
5.now sorry h5 buy white g captures on
h5 and now King to h4 and here we have h
6 and we have King back to h3 if you
play King captures here then you get
rook to g2 and there's not really all
that much you can do King captures rook
captures the pawn is on the dark square
you cannot defend it with the bishop any
move you making chapters and now being
up the exchange and the up an extra pass
pawn is completely winning
so after h6 we have King back to h3 and
now it seems a kind of difficult to
break through a position like this but
not really
Capablanca simply pushes h4 and it is in
this position that Frank James Marshall
resigned the game animal 49 as there's
nothing to do if you capture then it's a
rope - H - checkmate
it's a mating one if you capture with
the pawn then again you will get Luke to
d3 check pick up the bishop there there
are no tricks here and after h4 if you
completely you know disregard the pawn
you play something like Bishop to f7
then comes H captures on g3 and after
King captures you will play Rudy three
check King will have to move and then
after you capture this you have now two
passports and and you're up the exchange
again completely winning there are no
tricks here so like we said 13th game of
the match Papa Blanca is already six
points in the lead the result is seven
to one so couple monocot needs only one
more game to win this match we will show
this game and talk a little bit more
about this match and we will show you
that game that Marshall won as it is a
it is a beautiful game and it wouldn't
be fair to show only the games that
kappa blanka won but yeah we're gonna
definitely talk a bit more about this
match but in the next video so I do hope
you enjoyed this one I would like to
thank one Alejandro there are marrow
agüero proc Hermione
Bruce Robins Brock portal and Denmark
Coolio for a contribution to my channel
I think a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video so you're thankful for watching
and I will see you soon with another
nice game from the match marshall vs
kappa blanka but we also have the tata
steel starting so we're gonna be
covering those two events simultaneously
as usual
thank you all and I'll see you soon